all right so you've probably all seen
this plot this is the number of
sequences in GenBank per year and its
current as of 2014 and this volume of
data is growing exponentially
this has been talked about and it's
supposed to several problems one problem
is computing on the data
another problem is storing it and other
problem is transmitting it it's tempting
to think that cloud computing can solve
this problem and it can save some money
and provide flexibility but the problem
is that it doesn't address the
fundamental issue which is that cloud
computing still constrained by Moore's
law and if you want to take advantage of
cloud computing you have to transmit the
data up to Amazon or wherever and it
helps to be able to compress the data in
an efficient way now this is the same
data but on a log scale and this is the
growth of computing computing power
according to the top 500 supercomputers
supercomputers list and this is the
growth of GenBank so they're on
different exponents this is kind of a
problem well one thing we can do to help
with this is to take advantage of
redundancy and data and this is where
compression is going to come in now this
is just a little cartoon showing the
sizes of several fruit fly genomes and
here we've taken similans and yourself
of Drosophila Cecilia and removed what's
redundant between them the black bar is
so the yellow bar is the size of su
Shelia's genome the red bar is the size
of simulants genome if we combine them
and show only what's unique among the
two we get the
which is only a little bigger than
Cecilia and if we go a little further
and bring in Drosophila melanogaster
well the the unique date is a little
bigger but still we're doing better even
when we bring in much more distantly
related species we see that the unique
data is relatively small compared to the
concatenated set of all the genomes all
right so so maybe compression is useful
in looking at genomic data so I'm gonna
this talk is going to basically comprise
three parts first I'm going to give a
little bit of general background on
compression most of this stuff is more
than twenty years old some of that's a
lot older than that talk about
compression in terms of storage and
transmission for genomic data and then
talk about what we call compressive
genomics which is how you can take
advantage of compression not just to
save space but also to save time I'll
note that storage and transmission are
have very similar requirements in other
words if you zip a file it saves space
on disk and it's less to send over the
network but there are some important
differences for example if you're
transmitting data over the network it's
nice to be able to do things as it
streams and not have to wait until the
whole files downloaded to be able to
work on it all right
so jumping right in
forgive me I got a little bit of a cough
as well so Shannon in 1948 demonstrated
a fundamental lower bound on on the size
of a of a data set if you don't want to
lose data or you could think of this as
a fundamental upper bound on how good a
compression ratio can be so if we have n
random variables from some source and
each of those variables has a given
entropy H of X which is this is just
Shannon entropy it's the number of it's
basically a measure of the surprisal of
of a of an observation how different is
it from all the other observations
coming from that source if we have n of
those they cannot be compressed into
fewer than n H of X bits without loss of
information all right so this sets a
bound on how many bits are needed to
compress any data source measured in
terms of this unless we're willing to
throw away information so what can we do
if we want better compression well one
thing we can do is try to approach that
Shannon limit as efficiently as possible
we want compression to be fast we want
decompression to be fast that's often
more important and maybe we can leverage
some tricks to get closer to that limit
more efficiently the other thing we
might consider is being willing to throw
away information we are all familiar
with JPEG or MPEG compression for photos
and music and video that's what this is
doing it's throwing away the information
that we don't think is going to matter
in the end so how might we approach the
Shannon limit I'm going to talk about
four approaches that are not new but are
kind of fundamental in that a lot of the
other things I'm going to present build
on them
all right so Huffman coding gives us a
variable length prefix code so that the
more frequent symbols that the
observations we see more often take
fewer bits to represent so let's think
about DNA right we've got four bases a C
T and G and well if we want to be really
naive we could use a full byte to store
each one this is what a FASTA file does
this isn't really a good idea I'm gonna
be slightly more clever and realized
that we will need two bits only need two
bits per symbol to represent this
alphabet this is ignoring things like
ends for no call and so on now where
this gets interesting is suppose we have
some real bias it turns out that
Plasmodium falciparum which is one of
the malaria parasites has a only 20% GC
content which is kind of wild it's
eighty percent eighty so what would
happen if we built a Huffman code for a
genomic sequence of falciparum well
we've got our four bases and we're gonna
list the frequency of each base I'm
saying if it's eighty percent eighty
then it's for simplicity sake it's gonna
be forty percent a forty percent T ten
percent C 10 percent G and then what we
do is we take the two least frequent of
these leaves and we're going to build a
binary tree so we're gonna join those
two and the combined frequency is point
two and then we're gonna take the the
next least frequent now we're breaking
ties arbitrarily here but let's just
take T bring it into our binary tree
we've got a combined frequency of point
six and then finally our a and that
fills out the probability and then what
we're gonna do is label this we're going
to start out here and we're going to
call it zero and if this is zero then
the
whole rest of the tree is one and then
we're gonna go down this tree aways and
append a zero on this side and a one on
that side and we're going to append a 0
here and a 1 here and the important
thing about this this is essential is
that no symbol here is a prefix of any
other now I'm not counting the
intermediary ones here but 1 1 1 1 1 0 1
0 and 0 have no common prefixes no nice
you take none no one of them is a prefix
of another which means we can take a
sequence of them and uniquely decode
them there's no ambiguity well what does
this give us well then I even coding was
2 bits per base the Huffman coding turns
out if we look at the frequency and the
number of bits in the code word well a
occurs 40 percent of the time but only
requires one bit turns out we get to a
net of one point eight bits per base so
this is a small savings but this is also
a pretty trivial example and you might
actually have uneven bias if you were
talking about compressing a long set of
transcripts rather than here assuming
that we've got two strands and so a and
T have the same frequency and so on all
right so this is Huffman coding you
build a prefix tree and use non prefix
code words to represent symbols and the
smallest code words are given to the
most frequent symbols so in the
expectation we'll use very small code
words a lot of the time another
old technique that and I'm covering
these because they are essential to this
many of the state-of-the-art compressors
right these are really tools that are
still being built upon so arithmetic
coding encodes an entire message as some
number some high precision number and
the way it does this is it divides up
the number line between 0 and 1 so here
we've got our scene for the sake of
simplicity are same frequencies and if
we want to divide up the number line
between 0 & 1 we're gonna put a in the
range the half open interval 0 to 0.4 T
in the half open interval point for 2.8
G point 8 2 point 9 and C point 9 to 1
and then how could we actually use this
well it's essentially a recursive
algorithm let's let's take everybody's
favorite short nucleotide string Gattaca
and see how we did encode it well we
start with G I hope you guys can read
these numbers but doesn't really matter
so G falls in the range point eight to
0.9 all right so we're gonna start there
and expand that range essentially map
that range back to the whole interval
again and say that well now for our
second letter a is going to be in the
range point eight two point eight for T
from point eight four two point eight
eight G from point eight eight and point
eight nine and C from point eight nine
ten point nine so this whole range fits
within this little window and we're
gonna since the second letter is a
choose a and we're gonna recurse do the
same thing and now our new window is
point eight two point eight four he is
gonna fall in this window same thing we
just get to more and more decimal places
and finally
we end and say well we're at the I go
we're at the might as well represent the
beginning of this interval the last
letters the a so 0.82 for 704 stores
this message
well the neat thing is now we've got a
uniquely decodable number that
represents our string there are a few
problems first is how do we know in the
message ends and the answer to that is I
lied we need a stop symbol but I didn't
want to complicate the picture we either
need to stop symbol or we can only store
fixed-length messages the other problem
especially for those of you who know
something about computer architecture is
that floating-point precision rapidly
breaks this for any reasonable length of
message and/or the fact that
floating-point numbers are imprecise so
there is an integer version of this
which has some magic rules as is a
little unsatisfying but it's been used
for years
more recently rodionov and folk of came
out with a treatment using p-adic
arithmetic which is really cool I'm not
going to get into it here but it
basically solves this this sort of
unsatisfying problem the magic rules go
away and it turns out there's a nice
fixed precision treatment to this so
look it up if you're interested and
another interesting little aside is that
Huffman coding turns out to be a
specialized case of this it's less
likely to be optimal in the sense of
reaching that Shannon limit okay
another technique that we're gonna see
show up is
Huffman coding is less likely to reach
the to approach the Shannon limit or
it's not going to get as close to the
Shannon limit as good implementation of
arithmetic coding another thing that can
be done with arithmetic coding I should
mention is that that frequency table
could be changed it can be adaptive so
it doesn't need to be a predetermined
frequency table that's fixed for the
whole message Shannon no - it's really
not in fact the the closest there there
was work in the 90s
Gallagher codes reached closer to the
Shannon limit then than had previously
been done by you have new codes are much
older
it's truly yeah if if it's truly iid but
it's not always going to pick out
okay yeah okay so next I want to briefly
mention Lempel Ziv I I wasn't sure
yesterday I gather it Dan guess who may
have already talked about it but
basically so I'll be brief here as I
will with burrows-wheeler the idea is to
slide a fixed-length window along a
sequence and replace already seen
patterns up to some maximum length and
this is its big limitation and so you
know we've got our string again slightly
modified so we have some little ringer
of redundancy in here and we slide a
window along and as soon as we hit
something that we've seen before we can
replace it with a pointer to where we
saw it well it's at position 1 if this
is 0 indexed and the length from there
that occurs here limitations of this are
that we typically want this tuple to be
stored in a machine word maybe 32 bits
maybe 64 bits and so there's a trade-off
between the size of the pointer and the
length that we can that we can
efficiently store so maybe we we want to
be able to jump really far back in
sequence that bounds how much of a
repeated sequence we can store right
away but this is efficient it's used in
gzip
zip PNG compression many other areas and
yes indeed there's the pointer in the
length
Burroughs will transform I think has
been talked about enough here so I'm I'm
only going to say that it is block
sorting compression it is not itself a
compressor it's a way to sort input
reversibly it in efficient space such
that it lends itself to run length
encoding right what we get is an is a
lexicographically sorted string that we
know how to unscramble back into what it
came from and because it's
lexicographically sorted it can be run
length encoding very efficiently ok so
now i want to get into genomic
compressors so we want to get close to
the Shannon limit efficiently why not
just use a general-purpose compressor in
other words why not just take fast a
files or fast queue files and run gzip
and this is actually done right bam
files are essentially so bam uses a nice
little library called B's EGF it's
blocked gzip and that solves the
random-access problem we can now now
seek to some location within our big
compressed file and only uncompress a
small part of it but really there are
different kinds of data we're interested
in compressing there's sequence data and
there are also quality scores if we're
talking about next-gen sequencing read
data and there's one quality score per
base and when we're talking about how
much uncompressed space these require or
how much compressed space our sequence
is only a four-letter alphabet but our
quality scores we're talking about
Fred's scores from aluminum R until
recently a 40 value range so there's a
higher dynamic range here
there's more information content per
position so it's going to require more
space the other thing is that with maybe
a few exceptions I think we want our
compression of sequence to be lossless
you know there might be cases where
we're okay with approximate you know
some amount of loss but generally
speaking sequence compression should be
lossless quality score of compression
lossy compression might be okay we might
be okay with throwing away some amount
of data and I'm gonna get to that a
little later the other way to think
about this is can we pre-process the
data in some way that general-purpose
compressors can do a better job than if
we naively gzipped our fast queue file
so we want to try to take advantage of
structure now one way to do this is to
store differences from a reference if
we've got a reference genome for
whatever we're sequencing even though
Leo R said we should never align to that
reference if we do we can compress by
storing only the differences from it the
other option is if we don't have a
reference we can still cluster
similarities among reads and talk about
a few ways that this er is done that's
important when we don't have references
for because we don't have references for
every species we don't always have
reference data for what we're sequencing
so the very first technique I want to
talk about is called scales and I
apologize if I butchered it all because
this comes out of Jenks lab this is a
reference free compressor that uses
something called a locally consistent
encoding which I'll try to explain what
it does is end up bucketing reads by
substrings
and this improves both the runtime and
compression of a modified LZ levels of
compressor that's
run on the result so in other words here
we're noticing we're going to notice a
pattern in the data and rearrange the
data in such a way that a
general-purpose compressor does a better
job of it so alright here's here's the
locally consistent encoding algorithm
first I'll just tell you the steps and
then show you a short example we're
going to identify local Maxima in a
sequence and what do I mean by that
we're going to impose some
lexicographical ordering right AC G and
T we can turn them into zero one two
three and three will always be a local
maximum zero will always be a local
minimum so we're gonna identify local
Maxima then we're gonna identify any
local minima that aren't next to a
maximum we're gonna partition the string
based on those and we're going to extend
those partitions left and right to come
up with blocks and these blocks are
gonna be useful now I'm gonna show a non
general case of this the paper has a
exploitive explanation of the more
general case that only handles strings
of the form X Oh X where this doesn't
actually have to be 0 but it doesn't
handle tandem repeats turns out that the
more general version does so let's take
a string that happens to fit this
pattern and so it's got a 0 in the
middle I just colored it red so you see
it's the thing in the middle and we're
gonna I've bolded turns out there are no
local minima here that are not next to a
local maximum so it's all local Maxima
I've bolded them now then we partition
on each side of each maximum and on the
ends so we're just breaking this up and
extending left and right we get these
overlapping
blocks now what's interesting about this
is only that aside from the margins we
get the same block or blocks from both
sides of this right just by following
this rule of looking for local Maxima we
get 3 1 200 here and we get it here we
get 2 or 3 2 we get 2 or 3 2 and so on
so here we've got a nice little cura
stick that gives us consistent partition
or consistent core blocks from a long
string given that i mentioned the real
implementation is more complex in the
real implementation core blocks are
between 8 and 20 bases and it turns out
that 99 in the experiments shown in the
paper 99% of all high-throughput
sequencing reads of length greater than
50 include at least one core of length
less than or equal to 14 right so these
things empirically are good at pulling
out consistent blocks then you just
identify overlapping reads by these core
blocks and reorder them and lz77 does a
better job than it otherwise what
so the next and I'm not focusing on the
specific results for each of these
because I want the flavor of this to be
about the algorithmic techniques all of
these papers have were chosen because
they have excellent results not because
their authors are here that's a
coincidence
all right so DZ is another compressor
and this one is reference based so it
relies on having some mapping between
reads to from among reads to a reference
and the idea is to partition these reads
into blocks build a config that's all
the reads within a block and encode just
the locus for each read within the can
take so the idea is that most
differences between reads and a
reference should be shared by nearly all
the reads that map to that locus in the
reference in other words other than
sequencing error errors or highly
allelic regions all the reads that map
to a given locus should agree with one
another and we can store the few cases
where they don't by encoding those rare
differences so a little picture of this
so we've got a reference here this is
exactly the same example as in the paper
and we've got several reads that map to
this reference now here we see that all
of these reads disagree with the
reference in this position so this is
unlikely to be a sequencing error it's
probably a probably a snip here we've
got again a case where they all disagree
this is likely to be a deletion and here
we've got one of them disagreeing this
is more likely to be an
well
we can store this as the new consensus
sequence based on these reads so now
we've put this C here and a gap here and
we would also store out-of-band
this one difference we this is lossless
compression we don't want to ignore that
secret potential sequencing error or
potential Allu difference so we'd store
this and these can all be reconstructed
from this and this out-of-band
piece of information
DZ has a few other tricks up its sleeve
it tokenize --is the read names in a SAM
file those actually occupy a fair amount
of space as I said it uses lz77 it also
does and I'm gonna cover this later
lossy quality score compression just as
scales does and importantly it provides
random access hmm
so I'm gonna come back to the Quality
Score compression in a few minutes
all right another sequence compressor is
path Hank and Karl Kingsford is also
here so path Hank is reference based but
it does not actually do alignment to the
reference and it relies on a statistical
generative model of reads now path Hank
is a little different in that it was
demonstrated on RNA seek data there's
nothing about it that actually makes it
inappropriate for DNA so just going to
walk through a little example of how it
works we're going to use RNA alphabet
here so we're gonna again slide a little
camera window along our sequence and
we're gonna build a graph where each
Kaymer there's an edge between any
camera and the camera that immediately
precedes it
okay so initially this looks very
trivial as we slide this window along
we're going to build up a path but
we've seen this guy before it's already
here I there's supposed to be an edge
back and now there would be an edge from
here to here so basically we get some
paths in a graph that allows us to
recover our read and there's one node
per Kaymer in that graph and there's an
edge between k-mers if they are
sequential so all right so each read is
encoded as a path and they're encoded in
two different streams the first node of
each read path which is called the read
head is stored in one stream it's we
build a four Airy tree four for the four
letters of the alphabet of depth K and
we can just traverse that tree in a
fixed order emitting a 1 for any edge
that's actually present so we've got a
bit stream a 1 and a 0 if the edge is
not present so we get a bit stream that
comes from this tree of present k-mers
and so we can gzip that resulting bit
string but because the traversal order
of that tree is predetermined we can
recover the entire tree and thus recover
all the reads from the compressed bit
string will recover the heads of each
read and then the remaining nodes in the
tree the read tails are compressed using
an arithmetic coding now I mentioned one
advantage of an arithmetic coding is
that it can have an adaptive probability
distribution right we don't assume that
the emission probabilities of each
nucleotide are the same through a whole
genome in fact they can differ
significantly
each node in the graph gets its own
probability distribution so their reader
terminal
why you probably can't read the numbers
but here the y-axis is size as a
fraction of two bit encoding so lower is
better here and the x-axis is length of
Kaymer's these are two different read
sets here SiC k-mers of 16 so 16 Murs
give the best compression so that's what
they used I'm going to come back to that
a little later
after I talk about some quality score
compression I also want to talk about
mints which is another compressor from
Karl's lab this one is reference free
and I'm going to go through it kind of
quickly but it basically buckets reads
based on again short cameras 15 verse
mm-hmm and the idea is that it replaces
a common Kaymer with a pointer and
reorders the reads within each of these
buckets I'll show you what this ends up
doing but this again ends up boosting L
zip and gzip performance so here we've
got some Reed and this doesn't even show
up on here but we've got a common bucket
label which is a GC CA all right so this
I here is our label
because everything that goes into the
same bucket has this same label common
to it this is stored out-of-band
it's just a pointer to it and well there
isn't even a pointer there is an offset
where this occurred in the string and
then this is flipped so it's stored with
the suffix of the bucket label at the
beginning and the prefix at the end
along with the offset of the bucket
label and basically the idea is that the
compressor should be able to take
advantage of the fact that these all
follow the bucket label and there and
basically get better locality of of the
reads within a given bucket so this
again provides excellent compression and
runtime performance this transformation
is called split split swap read
transformation so they're chosen I
didn't go into the algorithm it's
covered well in the paper but basically
the so ties are broken according to
lexicographic ordering so we're gonna
choose early you know smaller buckets
first but basically they are the most
common elements I do leave 8 in a give
it so it's it's the most common aylmer
in a read and if that are in a k-mer and
if that's been seen before its mapped to
the same bucket and if it's not been
seen before then it becomes a new bucket
alright so this is what I wanted to
cover for sequence compression and I now
want to switch gears slightly and talk
about the quality
a problem because as I said this is a
bigger problem so alright so modern
sequencing equipment is not perfect and
introduces errors pull off that so-so
sequencing equipment gives quality
scores which are a measure of the
confidence in the base call at each
position now
the problem is as I said these take more
space in fact than the nucleotides if we
compress them naively so given reads
from a genome can we efficiently
compress quality scores without losing
too much accuracy okay in fact we might
even improve accuracy so the role of
quality scores in snip calling is we've
got some raw reads in a fast fast queue
file we're going to apologies Lior map
them to the reference and use something
like JDK or Sam tools to do variant
calling now in a compressed workflow we
might substitute so if we've done a
lossy compression of the quality scores
we can't recover the originals so now
we've got an alternate pipeline where we
have some new quality scores and we're
going to feed them into the rest of this
pipeline so
as I mentioned there's a greater dynamic
range than sequence data a compressor
could be lossless or lossy I'm going to
focus here on a couple of lossy
implementations so the first and this is
actually relatively recent although I
think there's more sophisticated work
that's been done earlier Illumina has
started and he turned this on recently
by default to support their cloud
platform collapsing the dynamic range
from 40 to 8 they call this eight
bidding they've demonstrated a small
effect on snip calling error and it's
available in cram but basically they
said well we're gonna take a no call and
it's still a no call we're gonna map 2
to 9 2 6 10 to 19 to 15 and so on and
there is a white paper on this if you
are curious it's worth a look
but I want to talk about a couple of
approaches that are adding a little more
interesting so so skulls also includes
lossy compression quality scores and the
observation here is that neighboring
quality scores are often similar this
observation is also going to be true and
something else I'm going to talk about
and the idea is reduce the dynamic range
apply arithmetic coding and you get a
small loss of snip calling accuracy as a
result so this is part of the I'm not
going into great detail here because
it's part of the skulls paper I already
talked about
there's also qbz from al seattle the two
of the co-authors on this paper are also
here so again talking about somebody
else's work who's present here the key
insight was the realization also that
neighboring quality scores are likely to
be correlated not necessarily similar
but correlated the work is based on rate
distortion theory the idea is disk
as little information as possible for a
desired bitrate and let's see the
approach is basically compute the
transition probabilities for a
first-order Markov model so walk along
our quality scores and look at how
likely a given score is based on its
predecessor construct a code book using
the lloyd-max algorithm which I am NOT
going to cover it's explained pretty
well in their paper and quantize the
input using that codebook and use again
an arithmetic coder so the thing I want
to go into only slightly here is here's
how the quantization works hmm we've got
a bunch of values and we've got these
these B's are the bin boundaries right
we're gonna say that anything in this
range B 0 to B 1 gets mapped to the same
value anything in this range B 1 to B 2
gets mapped to the same value and so on
however when it's decompressed and the
value is recovered it's not just mapped
to the midpoint of this interval which
would be commonly done it's mapped to
point in that interval that minimizes
the distortion of the original signal
okay so hopefully that's a slightly fair
cover of it
so qbz also shows significant
compression with minimal loss of or even
no loss of downstream snip calling
accuracy and finally for this section I
want to talk about work that came out of
our group called quartz so
what quartz does is it compresses
quality s'more scores by smoothing many
of them to kind of a unit value so
first what quartz does is it it relies
so it does rely on a reference but it
does not need to be a fully assembled
reference it relies on a corpus of reads
from which you generate a dictionary of
common camers and this only needs to be
done once typically per species so then
the compression works so we've got our
sequence and our quality scores and
we've got some reads so we're gonna
break so this is a read we're gonna
break this read into k-mers and these
are thirty tumors staggered every 16 so
they're half overlapping thirty tumors
and I'll talk about I mentioned the 15
MERS from Karl's work earlier I'm going
to talk about 30 tumors a little bit and
and why there's this difference here
what we want to do is find all hemming
neighbors within a Hamming distance of 1
so all immediate neighbors and the the
reason well get into why we use only
hemming distance of one in a minute and
two we want to be able to quickly
identify neighbors in a neighborhood of
the queries so we implement a
deterministic data structure that makes
that neighbor query very efficient now
we note where there's a difference
between the read and what we find in the
in the camer dictionary and we store the
quality value for so if we see a
difference in a hemming one neighbor
that is we consider that likely that
it's either an important error or it's a
real variation so that quality value is
stored and for all other positions so
here we found a difference for all other
positions they're simply smooth to a
uniform value and
the basic idea is that anything that's
anything where we have a hemming one
neighbor of the read in our corpus so
from this species that quality value is
likely to be important it either tells
us with high confidence that it's a real
variation or with low confidence that it
might be an error but in either case we
want to let the downstream pipeline use
it but all the rests that we're sort of
saying that there isn't a meaningful
difference between the values
represented here they all agree with
with the reference and if they were low
values that agreed with the reference
you know it's possible that that's a
variation that we're not seeing but we
don't know what the variant would have
been so there's little point in storing
it we can't do a positive variant call
from that so one of the challenges here
is that we need to quickly find all
three K Hamming neighbors of each cammer
y3k because at each position of our
Kaymer we've got some base there are
three other possibilities so there are
three K Hamming neighbors that is other
k-mers with only a Hamming distance of
one away naive approaches to this would
include a sorted list which is memory
efficient but CPU and cache inefficient
or a hash table which might be faster
but its memory and cache inefficient so
we use this locally sensitive hashing
approach and I'm gonna I'm gonna gloss
over this except to say that we project
each Kaymer onto a random K over tumor
so half the length forming a family of
hash functions and
there are two ways we can there are two
orthogonal ways we can break this we can
do this projection so I'll show you the
picture we basically have our dictionary
and we can cluster by the front half of
the camer
and that's one set of hash functions we
cluster by the back half of the camer
that's the orthogonal projection it's
another set of hash functions and we can
very quickly do a lookup for a k-mer
within this to see if it's present
within this table and so i don't want to
focus on results here but quartz does
the downside is quartz consumes a lot of
ram so it is not something easily run on
a laptop but on the other hand it gets
down to only 0.35 bits per quality score
it's very fast and the very surprising
thing is that quartz doesn't just not
significantly harm downstream based
calling accuracy it actually slightly
improved it on some test cases under the
metric of area under the ROC curve now
caveat to that is that if the
improvements are all out here on the ROC
curve and we really care about this area
it might not be a significant difference
but the reason this is a little
surprising is that when we talk about
lossy compression one of the goals is to
try to be able to recover the original
signal as closely as possible and here
we're throwing away a lot of the
original signal but the original signal
we care about is not the quality scores
at all right
those are artificial those are a measure
of what the sequencing machine has done
and where it's screwed up what we care
about is the underlying sequence and if
the quality scores are misleading with
regard to that sequence or just carry
additional noise along
and they're carrying no useful
information so if we can remove bits
that are used there and use those bits
for the quality scores that give us that
actually carry information then we
expect to be able to do at least as well
so I guess sort of the meta lesson here
is this that the real signal we care
about is not quality scores at all it's
it's the underlying sequence and I
mentioned this difference in k-mers I
wanted to this is sort of peripherally
relevant to compression but I wanted to
go over this so mints you found that 15
MERS were optimal for its implementation
for its case with 8 mer labels and this
makes sense because the labels are being
used as a almost as a seed for search
you don't want there to be too many of
them courts found 30 tumours were
optimal and that's because they're being
used in a different way they're being
used to look for hemming one neighbors
so if we think about a given genome it's
not unlikely that all possible eight
MERS may exist if we go even smaller
where we expect that all formers
probably exist in a given genome but
most 30 tumors may not and when they do
they tend to be unique or almost unique
with except for with the exception of
kind of repeats and low-complexity
regions and so on in fact for the human
genome with k equal to 16 the camer a 16
where only is only unique 21.8% of the
time and at hamming distance one it's
almost never unique 30 tumor is unique
eighty five point seven percent of the
time and at a hemming distance of one
it's still unique almost eighty percent
of the time so this is I think an
interesting result the lesson to be
drawn from this I think is that
sighs of k-mers matters in multiple ways
in terms of efficiency and in terms of
what question are you using them to ask
another picture of this is x axis is
Kaymer length thirty-two here sixteen
here and here's the number of 'lose I
identified for this is just the total
number of unambiguous low sigh and the
number of unambiguous low sigh at having
distance of one yeah it's gonna be
what's both its algorithm specific right
what question are you asking with the
camer this is not in any way suggesting
that mints should have used a thirty
tumor or that court should have used a
sixteen where but it is also very much
data specific and I'm gonna yeah I'm
gonna talk in the last part of this I'm
going to talk about almost lied on that
but I'm gonna talk a little about kind
of the structure of data and I think I
will answer your question in a few
minutes I think I've got a picture that
will nicely answer your question so the
other way to look at this is if we want
to ensure that there's at most
so why didn't why didn't use longer
k-mers inc quartz we want to ensure that
there's at most one sequencing error per
Kaymer
because looking at further handing non
neighbors but looking into a larger
radius of hamming distance gets
exponentially more expensive if we
assume that there's an independence of
errors then for some error rate P under
a binomial distribution the likelihood
of having L errors ends up something
like this at a 1% error rate 30 tumors
are 2 percent likely to have two or more
errors but 60 formers are 13% likely to
have two or more errors
and at a two percent error rate 30
tumors are 13% likely to have two or
more errors but 60 formers are more than
a third likely to have two or more
errors so if we want to try to reduce
the chances that we have more than one
sequencing error 30 tumors make sense
for this sort of neighbor neighbor
investigation all right I want to change
gears for the last part of this and talk
about compression for speed I already
showed you this picture but usually we
think of compression as a space time
trade-off yes I mean the eastern ones of
any part of the scene of the UK poll the
quality scores if a read doesn't map
anywhere in the genome yeah those
quality scores are preserved yeah
because we don't know what to say about
them yeah
okay so usually we think of yes
yeah so if you have so for the purposes
of courts where the the the mapping so
yes you can have a read that maps well
to multiple low sigh what do you do if
for example one of those lows I says you
should throw away these quality scores
and the other one says you should not
it's the conservative answer don't throw
them away but there has to be some
cutoff because you know you could have
reads that map well too many low side
without a significant difference in
mapping quality and I actually would
have to check with William about how
that's handled kind of it where it where
is the boundary drawn and why yeah
improved over the lossless case it's for
maybe of the sequential machine because
of technology or maybe it's because they
variant calling algorithms I'm not using
the quiet discs or they shoot it could
be either could be both I think for a
Lumina reads I mean my sense is that and
I'm not an expert on the sequencing
equipment itself my sense is that they
have a pretty good handle on their error
model I'm not convinced that's as true
for some of the more recent next
next-gen sequencing systems but for
Illumina reads like that's my sense as
far as the downstream calling you know
there's some work not yet published that
suggests that there are some real
problems with some of the base calling
approaches and sensitivity to ordering
of reads
and so on and this you know it's it's
possible that you were seeing an
artifact of that of non-determinism in
base calling yeah there there are a
bunch of possibilities in the quality
score compression like for quartz yeah
yeah all of these would preserve the the
read name or read ID that's you need to
be able to reconstruct that yeah there
are some approaches that do some
transformations on that you know Thoth
as I mentioned tokenizing the read name
so that it's more efficiently compressed
but that's still lossless the only thing
that any of these approaches are excuse
me discarding information on would be
the quality values themselves all right
so changing gears I want to talk a
little bit about compressive genomics so
normally we think of compression is a
space time trade-off it takes time to
compress anything it's now in a form we
can't easily analyze for many forms of
analysis so we need to then take time to
decompress it now maybe we only want to
analyze a little part so we only need to
decompress that little part but it's
still a space time trade-off just a
difference in how much and what I want
to talk about is some work from our lab
on how we can actually use compression
to speed up analysis so parlo Michael
Bay and Bonnie Berger came out with what
they termed compressive genomics in 2012
with the paper of that title collapse
which is compressively accelerated blast
and we then had a protein version so
that was four nucleotide blast and blat
search we had a protein variant of this
at isnb in 2013 and the key to both of
is that blast uses a seed and extend
approach right we find short Kaymer's
use them as a heuristic to try to extend
an alignment and the problem is a lot of
times blast has to extend has to try to
extend on seeds that don't lead anywhere
so what both of these did is use
compression to reduce the search space
so I want to walk through how the cub
lasts or specifically cub last pea
compression works and you're gonna find
it's actually not too different from
Lempel Ziv with one important difference
so we're gonna initialize something
called a course database and this is
going to be the thing that we're
actually gonna be able to search easily
and we get some sequence we want to
compress now initially the database is
empty so we're going to put our first
sequence into the database and what
we're gonna do is index it so every
Kaymer and here i've got k equal to 4 we
wouldn't actually use for necessarily we
actually use 6 for an amino acid
alphabet we use more like 10 or 12 for a
nucleotide alphabet but we initialize a
complete seed table with every Kaymer we
see in here and another sequence comes
along and the seed table contains
pointers back to the location of the
seat of the camer in here another
sequence comes along well what we do is
we slide a k-mer window along it and we
see if we've seen that Kaymer before
well we haven't seen lq st we haven't
seen q st a well you have seen st AQ
rather conveniently it's right at the
beginning of this other sequence and so
we try to extend just like last would
first we do a an uncapped extension we
just greedily try to add characters
until we run into a mismatch the D and
the Q do not match and then we try a
gapped extension
so here we find that if we do a sequence
alignment of these two they match with a
couple of differences and those
differences we can store so up to here
we could and this match can't continue
here because there's no more sequence
here or maybe there's sequence that
doesn't match at all so we can
completely reconstruct this sequence
thus far by the pointer to by by a
pointer back to here and encoding these
couple of differences the lq at the
beginning here q r and v n so as i said
this is like Lempel Ziv except here
we're allowing differences and storing
them according to a couple of parameters
we this part of sequence doesn't match
anything so it again goes into the
course database so as I mentioned this
is lossless compression so we can
recover the original but what's
important is we've got this course
database which has what turned out to be
the unique exemplars of our original set
of sequences so the specific parameters
for compression for protein sequences we
allow we require 70% sequence identity
they must be at least 40 residues for a
match and so on those parameters are all
in the is MV paper how do we actually
use this to do a search well we've got
some query sequence and we've got that
course database I mentioned well we
first do a course search and this is
just using blast blast P sy blast
what-have-you and we get some hits from
that now this course database is a
strict subset of the original database
that we wanted to search so the course
hits are a subset of the hits we would
get if we search the original database
but then we use each course
and reconstruct all the candidates that
it from the original database again this
was lossy compression so we can reverse
it and we get some candidate hits some
maybe hits and this this search was done
with a pretty loose threshold on what
counts as a hit we searched this set of
candidates again and call this fine
search here we're using blast again but
with the parameters the user would want
for for a threshold and we get some set
of results now on a simulated data set
where we multiplied with mutation yeast
genome standard blast PA takes as you
would expect roughly linear time in the
size of the database this inflection
point is a actually a cache artifact and
the compressively accelerated version
gets much closer to almost looking like
constant time over as the data set grows
now this was simulated data if we look
at real data growth on a protein
sequence database NCBI is a non
redundant database again these are just
three snapshots because you can't go
back and get historical versions of that
easily this is the time taken for blast
and this is the time taken for
compressive accelerated blast we've also
applied this to metagenomics and it's
really a similar problem except given
reads from a microbiome
these are nucleotide reads we want to
translate each one and match them to
protein data set so each read is turned
into a set of possible reading frames
and searched against a protein database
there are several tools for the standard
tool for this was until very recently
snow blast ax rap search - and Dimond
are much more
recent approaches and we basically
applied this same compressive
acceleration using diamond to get pretty
significant speed gains for metagenomic
mapping with minimal loss of accuracy so
the key idea here actually though is
that compression is clustering now when
we compress data we want to cluster
similar entities or sub entities right
these don't have to be entire sequences
they don't have to be entire reads we're
looking for similarity but there is a
relationship between compression and
clustering so with compression we only
want to store the common parts once and
with compressive acceleration we want to
only analyze the common parts once so
let me show you a picture of kind of how
this works
so in compressive genomics we do a
cluster based search we have some
cluster centers and those partition
space in some way so these the cluster
centers are just the course sequences
from that course database I showed you
from the point of view of a query which
is that little green guy there we can
search over just the cluster centers
with some permissive radius this is
course search and identify the clusters
that they belong to so we hit these
three cluster centers we need to look
inside these three clusters and we can
search those clusters with the smaller
radius that the user actually wants now
why can we get away with this well due
to the triangle inequality so suppose we
have clusters with some radius R sub C
and for any similarity search query
for any point within a distance-r of
that query since it's in a cluster whose
center is at most R sub C away by the
triangle inequality that cluster Center
can't be more than R plus R sub C away
from our query so we only need to search
the clusters that have centers within
that distance R plus R sub C of the
query now big caveat here is that not
all distance functions obey the triangle
inequality and in fact many of the
natural ones we want on string data do
not obey the triangle inequality so
there's a little bit of potential loss
of recall but it turns out that this is
rare and tends to be on the boundaries
of the search thresholds wanted so yeah
well that's exactly right so they are
near metrics or approximate metrics and
we expect that if the triangle
inequality is almost always in practice
observed even for something that's not a
metric then we will almost always find
the hits that we want now some things
are really bad metrics and unfortunately
if we're talking about blast the the
threshold input is avalue which doesn't
really approach being a metric but it
turns out that in practice we loosen the
course search evaluate all the hits all
right so I want to talk a little bit
about next-gen sequencing analysis and
how this applies I think we have about
10 minutes what yeah I mean how are we
okay so
all right yeah sure sure me backup the
first the initial search all right so
we've got the red ones are the course
examples those are the entries in the
course database that's just the
partitioning we're gonna search all of
them to find the ones that are within
this radius okay because we don't have a
yes so we the important thing I didn't
say is that well though I've put these
in some imaginary coordinate system we
don't have a coordinate system so we
actually defined the ones within this
ball we do have to consider every one
the idea is that the number of these
should be far less than the number of
entries in the full database okay there
that's that's what I'm covering right at
the end and I think in the interest of
time I'm actually going to I'm going to
skip the variant calling stuff because
you asked that question you just skip
over this other than to say we've
essentially applied this to read mapping
as well in a paper that was just
accepted and both best mapping and all
mapping also lend themselves to this and
because you can cluster reads as well as
entries in a reference genome yet pretty
significant gains again this is this
essentially the same picture because
it's virtually the same idea except that
here you've got a by partition because
you're clustering both sides of the well
because you've got to by partition your
and you're doing clustering on both
sides you've got
games on both sides of it let's see
so applied to read mapping this gets
pretty significant runtime gains over
bowtie 2 and bwa and even over misses
fast ultra when we're talking about all
mapping so the coming back to the yeah I
just totally forgot is there some casual
useless going on in the way you perform
these searches no no there's no cache
obliviousness going on trying to do that
might help a lot
now if the underline what this is really
doing is boosting an existing search
tool and if that search tool does take
advantage of cache obliviousness right
so missus fast obviously is you know has
is cache oblivious I don't believe we've
tried boosting misses fast itself or we
tried and it got marginal get if any
gains but there so Dimond which I
mentioned with respect to metagenomics
search does have some cache
obliviousness baked in and it's still
gains although not as much as blast X
did so you know at a certain point as
you apply all of these other
optimization techniques some of the
gains we can get through compression are
preserved and because they're orthogonal
gains and some of the gains go away
so the camer question of is this a
property of the data this is really
so I want to talk about astronomy for a
second so this is a hertzsprung-russell
diagram and what this is is a plot of
temperature of a star versus its
luminosity and what does this have to do
with genomic data one thing which is
that all the data points in here come
from a generative process that is
constrained by physical law and that's
true of living genomes too and what's
interesting here is that so these are
what are called main sequence stars the
Sun is one of the you know somewhere in
here and they they are constrained to a
subspace here but it's well it's a lower
dimensional subspace it's not a lot
lower dimensional right it still spans a
significant region of the Cartesian
space and there are other kinds of stars
that can exist but most of this space is
not occupied in fact we don't think can
be occupied now if we're looking at
genomic data the kind of search I talked
about could be like a grid search or
something like that where you just look
in regions this only gives you constant
factor gains and I think genomic data
looks very different and this is so this
is just a cartoon this is not a real
plot of real data partly because all the
data sets we're talking about are very
highly dimensional and if we want to
visualize them as soon as we reduce
dimensionality we lose any structure so
we for now have to rely on cartoons but
this is sort of like a imagine imagine a
Tree of Life where most genomes tend to
be similar to a bunch of other genomes
or most protein sequences have
similarities to a bunch of others
and you do get significant divergence
but that divergence isn't spread
uniformly through space it's constrained
along branches that are evolutionarily
feasible
so if we cluster this space we see that
we still need far fewer clusters we
compress this space we still need far
fewer clusters then we would need to
cover the entire feasible space so why
does this sort of search work and what
are the what are the complexity bounds
on it well so we've got this sort of
search tree where these are the course
entries or our cluster representatives
and these are the things they represent
so course search is done on this spine
and we look at some representatives we
expand them down and do a fine search on
the things they represent so the time
should be on the order of course search
and find search time but course search
is K that's the number of clusters we
end up with
that's an emergent property it's not an
input property so let's look and see if
we can get any sense of what's going on
with K so metric entropy at a given
distance scale is the number of balls
that can fit on a shape now in normal I
don't know enough about the background
of people here to know if people are
comfortable with fractal geometry but
fractal geometry is the idea that for
some shapes the number of balls or the
number of rulers will scale more than
linearly as their size shrinks so we're
going to define the metric entropy for
some data set as the largest number of
points in the data set such that they
are row separated for some radius Rho
and the Minkowski dimension is the limit
as that radius goes to zero but we're
actually doing kind of a discrete
version of this so here we're going to
say that D is the dimension that
maximizes the
metric entropy maximizes the number of
these balls these clusters we need to
cover the space so for some radius Rho
that we is our maximum cluster radius if
we have K clusters then K is bounded by
the metric entropy of the dataset so our
search is on the order of the metric
entropy plus defined search now what
about the fine search well fine search
is this is a search over the set F but F
is the Union over a set of spheres or
balls or hyper spheres around our query
at the core search radius R plus R sub C
there that sets we have to consider in
our find search now that's a subset just
due to basic geometry of a ball of this
larger radius around the query so the
size of our fine search set the number
of things we have to consider in the
find search is bounded by this which is
approximately this now here D is the
fractal dimension at the radii we're
searching at and this is just the output
size this is how many items within our
database are within radius R of query Q
well we have to consider them because
we're going to output them the idea is
that doubling the search radius
increases the number of hits by at most
two to the D so if do if D is high this
is bad when we have to do our find
search but it turns out so this is our
final complexity and we've got the
course search here the fine search here
mm-hmm just another quick picture of
this is that we've got to consider
K
clusters we then have to expand them and
consider this many clusters during fine
search and for each of them we have this
term so the key here is that I think I
showed you with that earlier picture
that this is in practice much smaller
than the number of points in the
database but also that the fractal
dimension is quite low so just to give a
quick intuition about that because this
also relates to another question if we
consider some point here and two radii
around it low fractal dimension means
that as we increase this radius we don't
add a huge number of more points to the
larger circle higher fractal dimension
as we see over here would mean that we
more if this is two dimensional
quadratically increase the number of
points that we'd have to consider so I
think this why we see data that kind of
behave like this in genomics is that
genomics are a product of evolution and
thus are constrained by natural law so
quick summary lossless lossless
compression is bounded by Shannon lossy
compression can go further
clever pre-processing of reads and we
went over several examples of this can
boost standard compressors it all comes
down to the structure of the data we
want to minimize number of bits per base
if we're talking about sequence data
identify common sub strings and find
correlations among quality scores and
where to go further from here new
sequencing technologies are going to
change a lot of this in terms of having
longer reads as we or discussed if we're
talking about quality scores this is
going to change the error models
a lot and existing compressors may not
work so well for something like PacBio
reeds where there are a lot of in Dells
it's longer more error-prone reeds
different sequencing technologies will
have different error models that have to
be considered and the compressive
acceleration I mentioned we've still
really only looked at for search and I'm
considering read mapping is still a form
of search if you're doing alignment
you're doing search of a form so can we
get some of those benefits with a more
general model Thanks
I think we have time for a couple
questions yeah I didn't show it I do
have that I think not in this stack of
slides but in practice for meta genomic
and for protein sequence data less than
two four we also looked at some non
sequence data for protein structure
roughly one and four chemical graph
structure actually less than one so low
within the search radii that we're
looking at and then obviously it's
dependent on the range estimating it by
sampling over a data set yeah yeah so
you're just looking at you know take two
radii and we're not shrinking these to
zero because we're interested in the
discrete form how many points are in
this radius how many points are in this
what's the ratio between the radii and
the number of points take the log
so well so BAM is a file format right so
BAM is a binary version of Sam so Sam
stores sequences and it also stores
alignments it also stores quality not
just the quality scores from Reedsburg
quality of the alignment BAM is a binary
version of that that is compressed using
gzip blocked gzip so there's random
access and any so first of all any
compressor liking think of bamas
compressor can be bolted on after
something that's doing transformation of
the data so if you're talking about the
quality scores you could do quartz style
or qvz style quantization or smoothing
of those quality scores and then run
your whatever is downstream and should
gain advantage the other thing is if
reads are reordered in a clever way so
that more similar reads are near one
another you can just think of this as a
permutation of the original fast queue
file you will likely get better locality
of similarity between reads and so
compressor will will work better there's
a caveat which is that some downs some
snip colors are not even deterministic
with respect to the order of the reads
and I believe there's a paper coming out
soon about that nothing will sighs yeah
yeah yeah which it's worrisome
well there's a there's a reason for it I
mean it's but yeah I mean the this sort
of thing is a throws a bit of a wrench
into the works when it when it comes to
compression because I mean if you're
talking about a lossless compressor for
read data this shouldn't mess up
downstream analysis and if it does
there's you know it's not the fault of
the compressor but the analysis tools
need to be looked at questions thanks